[Musique]
on va commencer Véronique par une une
pépite pépite ivelinoise bonjour à tous
et bienvenue dans ce numéro spécial du
Sky ah pardon il y avait des gens qui
passaient derrière toi ça m'a je pas que
tu tombes l'électric Park de Chatou
c'est terminé ce soir pour nous vous
savez salon de l'emploi géant toute la
journée une grande attention tu vas
tomber et rassurez-vous ça reviendra à
l'année prochaine avec et
l'agglomération de C1 en nieline ont
transformer le site olympique du salon
du
salon l'éleectric Park de Chatou c'est
terminé pour
nous son ambition promouvoir la musique
amplifiée dans C1 en
Yveline oublié de partir j'ai oublié de
partir son objectif promouvoir et
développer la musique amplifiée dans
550S en
yeline ça m'énerve et s'il y avait un ou
deux rendez-vous à surtout pas noter on
en a on en a dit quelquesuns il y en a
bien sûr beaucoup d'autres dans la
[Musique]
programmationattendis
pas on a rien ouais c'est ça on a plus
rien pass je vous passe un film
[Musique]
après ce repas quoi de mieux qu'une
balade digestive à
quelques et on se
trouve et on se trouve maintenant à
la et on se retrouve tout de suite
devant qui vient nous expliquer les
activités et parmi elles il y a le
karting mathil faut faire attention
parce que Nicolas dendr il avance tout
le temps quand il est devant la caméra
il
et dimanche petite journée
[Musique]
pépère c'est super bien
présenté alors on continue on continue
avec quoi on va continuer avec la bande
dessinée les comics et les romans
graphique
[Musique]
allez baisse-toi encore ouais là tu es
bien ah ouais tu es sexy
même cette arrivée répondait à une
demande de la population lesction les
réactions au micro de Julien Leroi
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information local sur tv78
nous sommes le lundi 9 septembre 9
octobre
pardon